see it's the first meeting of the
municipal Municipal
um year
what I should have said it's a first
meeting of the normal uh scrutiny
committee this year we did have a an
extraordinary meeting uh last Monday
um so welcome to everybody
it is being streamed live
um if we go into the agenda
um
attendances is the first item have we
had any apologies
apologies have been received from
councilors Carter German and Western and
Denise Western
uh John Holden has given his apologies
to me so yeah
uh item two is membership of the
committee just to note the appointments
and that of the chair and buy share
okay item three uh committee terms of
reference which has been circulated
are we okay with
with that
uh item four is the minutes of the 8th
of March
2023 seems a long time ago doesn't it
but uh
can we agree uh that record yeah
um item five is Declarations of
interests
has anybody got any
um Declaration of interest to declare no
item six questions from the public
don't think we have any do we have it
none have been received
okay thank you
now the one of the main items on the
agenda is the next one item seven which
is the Amy seven year review
and we've got Chris Morris and we've got
Steve adzed the exec member and we've
got Helen
so well well welcome to the meeting
um just hand over to
um Steve right thank you chair I'll just
do a brief instruction now hand over to
Chris and Helen to actually uh go for
the detail obviously uh hopefully
everyone's had a chance to look through
the slide pack which is uh they're
interesting I've seen various versions
over quite a period of time and it has
evolved a little slightly with you you
may have noticed alongside the review
we've actually also taken opportunity
to actually make changes to a number
with Amy services in particular waste
we've actually seen quite a significant
Improvement you may see a number of
slides there where there have been
improved obviously it's not 100 we're
not there yet or definitely all the way
but you can see that but the changes
made as part of the work of running
alongside the review it as contributed
to a quite a change the current uh Amy
staff all there and Senior managers have
actually uh working with us no
cooperatively now as you may remember
when the contract first opened up it was
a very different positions what we are
in now there was a on the we've actually
had no client team it was actually uh it
was all self-monitoring I think the
situation is now obviously we've got
we're developing quite a robust client
team to actually make sure we can
actually more clearly hold Amy to
account and that's actually is one of
the priorities for that Administration
so predominantly you will see uh in the
slide as well as that decarbonization is
one of our main themes is that one of
the things that stand out very much for
me uh aside that is actually uh this
whole thing is underpinned by
Communications how we communicate across
the piece whether it's to members
Community organizations especially ones
like terms of arts groups but also
members of the public as well and it's
actually getting those comms right and
actually make sure we have information
that's relevant to people as well uh
because sometimes you can produce a lot
of information but it's not always
necessarily what people want you can
sometimes too much and it gets lost in
the system but I think so making it that
relevant to people is going to be not
just in public but also to members as
well I mean we did have some feedback
sessions for members and they told the
sort of information they'd want and and
comms have been changing alongside of
that and and ultimately what I'll say
Obviously uh what what's uh what I said
to lots of things and parts groups as
well is like uh even when this report is
approved hopefully uh that that won't be
the end of the process there'll be
continual reviews over the coming period
and we're looking at how we can actually
work more closely with Community groups
and indeed uh an ultimate reviewing
aspects of the contract on an ongoing
basis so with that I'll hand over to
Chris and Helen to take you through it
and obviously if we're available to ask
you any questions uh
I don't allow you to take questions at
Jordan at the end of it yeah at the end
so yeah so please hold off and go
through the chat thank you
thanks very much Steve um
there's a fair bit of uh uh of slice to
go through
um thanks very much for this it's been a
quite a long process
um a seven year review I'll take you
through what I'm trying to do tonight
on the agenda the first thing is to look
at some of the contexts of uh of the
seven year review why we're doing it
um the governance around it uh what the
objectives were and the approach that
was taken
um secondly we're going to look at the
overall summary analysis so what changed
um and what has changed in terms of uh
in terms of
the relationship but also in terms of
performance for the contract
um a service based service review so
um elements were picked for the seven
year review which was seen as being uh
core to uh to uh to change from uh from
both and Amy under on the council point
of view
um
and also some next steps and timelines
so without further Ado I'll carry on
the context of it
um the slide says that this is a seven
to seven year review is a contractual
process
it is uh the contract itself is a
15-year contract with with Amy it's
based around a partnership model and
it's quite a sweeping large uh Beast of
a contract which has which has quite a
lot of areas without within it it's not
just a highways contract it's also where
it's also a waste contract it has
elements of Estates right the way
through to uh right the way through to
uh to Green spaces and
and within it that is a very very large
sweep of the services that we do in
terms of hard maintenance within the
contract
um
I think in terms of performance it had
its troubles
um and I think we we've always uh we've
always well certainly for the last few
years seen that though it's seen that
there were some issues within it
in fact uh I think from uh from this
committee we we looked at a potential
options within the contracts uh there
are no there is no break course within
the contract so it's all realistically
The Seven Year review is a mechanism
that we can use to come to an agreement
with Amy to actually try and make sure
that some of the things that have
changed in the last seven years
um are actually put right so in other
words is the contract fit for purpose in
terms of seven years later the world is
a different place having moved on seven
years later communication is done in a
different way the way that we uh the way
that we we react if you like to uh
um to invite to things that happen
within the environment also a changing
environment and a changing fiscal
um Market that we uh that we actually
existed
so realistically this seven year review
needs to be an agreement between Council
and Amy this is not a we want we will
give because it's the same contract that
we uh that we that we have
um and it's not an opportunity to
fundamentally change elements or
elements of it but it's an element it is
it's it's about how we work in certain
areas whether we can have certain
expectations counselor ads had already
mentioned things about decarbonization
which uh which is has obviously taken a
lot more precedence in the last in the
last few years and actually making sure
that that we have uh the basis and the
stable and the stable um stable basis if
you like to improve the contract through
the seven years
um
The Seven Year review isn't meant to be
a light switch it's not going to be
something that gets pressed and the uh
the contract moves from the dark into
the light
this has been a process that's been
taken that's taken nearly a year to uh
to get through
and within that year
um we've made changes already so we've
made changes to the way that we deliver
May changes to the way that we Monitor
and make changes to some of the targets
that we expect from the from from the
contract and that's actually built in to
uh to what we've put into into this
response
so
the other part of it is also to make
this this is seven years into a 15-year
contract it's to make the next seven
years into something that we can
actually actually have a basis for
change
uh it'll be naive to say that so the
next seven years will be exactly the
same as the previous seven years we know
that's not going to be true we're going
to face a lot more challenges and
challenges in terms of the highways
Network in terms of changes to waste
legislation and in terms of in terms of
changes to the expectations of the
customers that we've got in traffic
thank you
so what do we do
um we could have done bottom up and gone
through every single every single
service
realistically it this was more about
actually how we think about what the
services we do so a strategic approach
what are the Improvement objectives of
the council I think quite a lot of
people would have said waste needed to
be improved there were improvements that
were needed to the way that we look at
the green environment way to and also
and also how do we actually meet the
fiscal challenges that actually we've
got within within local government at
the moment
Improvement objectives of Amy
um the select will turn around and say
profit margin straight away and we
wouldn't hire and we wouldn't hide from
that the uh the the issue the issue
realistically though
um within a contractor all of the guys
who work in this car contract deal with
people in Trafford every day
getting the contract to work right for
both parties actually means less
problems for us also less problems for
Amy and actually the contract model in
order to make that profit margin means
that actually it has to work right if it
doesn't work right penalties get
penalties get taken off and then any
profit margin disappears fairly quickly
so realistically this was about trying
to find a mutual approach between the
council and Amy which is what the
council what the contract was set up to
do in the first place it was called the
one traffic partnership to make sure
that we could make partnership and
partnership decisions to make for the
best for the best for traffic Council
okay in terms of the in terms of um the
major areas we wanted to look at
um and proven additional to access to
additional funding to increase Capital
spend we made by that one of the first
uh on the first parts of the uh well
when the contract was set up one of the
first uh first questions was that was
that a lot of the capital or a lot of
the uh the money that went into the
contract
um to pay for paper Services was going
to be uh or excess money was going to be
made for him uh made from things like
commercial waste now that didn't turn
into something that was true yeah the
opportunity for commercial waste
probably is still there but but
realistically that that was not seen as
we're not seen as being something that
something that was there
but realistically there are
um to make the uh to make the contract
work in a year in a in a proper fashion
realistically money has to flow through
it to make sure that the uh make sure
that our Revenue Services are revenue
revenue services are supported
so what we've got to do is look together
an additional Capital schemes and we're
and there are lots of opportunities
within greater Manchester at the moment
to make sure that happens for instance
the uh for instance basically the uh the
capital spending coming from coming from
um
devolved government
but also the DFT itself
evolving service standards to meet the
changing needs of the customer that are
flexible for the next seven years what
does that mean we're in the we're in the
um we're in the Amazon generation we're
in the Twitter generation and people
want everything right now
um there is there's an expectation bias
now on on services that probably wasn't
there seven years ago certainly wasn't
in the pre in the in the previous bit
we've got to basically make sure that
our service standards when it comes to
communication but also in terms of those
service standards can evolve to meet to
meet a change a changing world of
expectation
but also in terms of limitations out
there for instance we have
um
issues with flooding that we would never
that we would never see never never seen
uh seen seven years ago we will we will
have issues with changes of standards
that come from central government and
it's how we actually react to those
delivering against the climate emergency
including reduced carbon emissions and
increased sustainability
uh we declared a climate emergency that
climate emergency wasn't there when the
contract started
how do we actually adapt and how do we
make sure that the uh that the contract
is fit for purpose to carry on that and
make sure it helps the helps the
contract oh it helps the council
uh meetings targets and also
we have a large partner a partner which
has targets itself that are that are
that are built into its uh into its
um into its uh project targets for the
next uh for the next few years that
should be part of our targets as well to
actually make sure that we make the most
of those opportunities that are there
improving efficiency and generating
additional income and growth
opportunities as I mentioned the fiscal
fiscal situation within this we've got
to make sure that uh that we have the
most efficient efficient way of working
which means doing things right first
time
and it also and that goes for both sides
of the both sides of the partnership and
also making making sure that we can we
can make any additional income where
where we can do a reasonable fashion to
uh to make sure that to make sure that
we can support services on the front
line
and finally and most importantly ensure
and improved customer customer focused
Service delivery it's a long one that
wasn't it and Communications to make
traffic a better place to live and work
I don't feel with that
I feel we're quite reactive still but
we've got to a point where we're able to
react
the next stage in terms of the seven
years is to actually make sure that
we're being more proactive and whether
that's in a waster in a waste field
where we can we can look at the months
ahead and we can see and we can spot
Trends so we can do that and then that
is that is something that's massively
important
making sure the communications through
our through our own
um through our own CMS system actually
is better
um and that we've got the data behind
what we do to support the new CMS system
when it comes into play
so what do we do we split up into
steering groups we have a Steering group
sorry with uh with basically members of
the exec on it uh to um to give us a
little bit guidance of the the areas
that we were looking at and the officer
team uh which uh which was mostly made
up of
um my team Plus members of members of
ABS Management uh with with joint review
groups and then service service working
groups that split down into the
individual individual subjects that I'll
talk about in a minute
um and in terms of the process well we
are where we are and that which is which
is right down second to bottom which is
very effectively the Amy solution around
making sure we've got the commercial
negotiation with someone with one or two
of the the elements so the idea is to
put the paper through and actually make
sure and actually make sure that we can
negotiate those commercial bits and then
move and then move on into the next
seven years where where we're in a an
area of area hopefully service
improvement through the uh through the
period
oh
okay okay overall summary of what we've
achieved
um
I hesitate to use the word service
improvement
I think we stabilize the service
um
and I'll I'll go on and give you some
some examples of that in a few minutes
but I think we've stabilized the uh uh
the uh the service of the of the OTP to
a point where it's delivering one-based
service and where we need to go next is
to actually make sure that that
productivity is is seen seen across the
piece within the within basically the
controls and the budgets that were given
for Capital
um I think through the last year people
will have hopefully experienced a uh an
element of uh
an element of improvement uh in certain
areas of the performance uh notably
around waste
um and in terms of some of the
visibility that we're given on some of
the other some of the other areas
um and I'll take I was into the little
bit of depth on that on governance in a
second
uh We've
we've already because because basically
there was some there was a uh an element
of were Amy going to continue
actually from uh from two to three years
ago the Improvement the the investment
within the contract died off a little
bit
going through this process actually
actually gave Amy an opportunity to uh
to invest and what we have seen is an
investment most notably in computer
systems which again I'll go into until
death which is back to him backed up the
performance that we've that we've got
enabled and enables not just Amy to
monitor their performance but also my
team to monitor their performance in a a
much more forensic work forensic manner
than we've ever ever been able to to do
before and so hopefully head off
problems quicker and deal with the
communications faster and actually get
the product better than uh than we've
done before and we perfect no we're not
and that one and that one that will
never leave it never leave my mouth but
what we are what we're what we're hoping
to do is to make sure that we've got a
data driven data-driven contract going
forward that we can react to
going forward
the whole thing is about continuous
Improvement
um basis is not enough we need to we
need to basically make sure that we can
continually improve utilizing data
within the within the contract better
and utilize some of the computer systems
I'll go and go into but also getting the
best out of people
um it's got to be a team
and
with a contractor working for us it's
therefore always pulled into Us and Them
in real terms
being the highways director Highway HDE
director it's actually us as well as the
as well as Amy so it's basically about
making sure that we're all aligned in
terms of in terms of what we're trying
to do and that for me is the basis of
successful contracts I'm not massively
short that's been happening before so
that's what we've got to try and change
with this with this uh with this seven
year review most of proposed changes
will go live from July 2023 but I think
as you'll see quite a lot of them have
absolutely already already happened
because they are performance Improvement
so governance service planning and
culture sounds very very dry but uh what
are we trying to do and we're trying to
make sure that the structure within the
contracts is more robust than it was
before that's not to say there wasn't a
governance structure before there was
but this is about making sure that the
governance actually is fit for purpose
in today's uh today's meaningful
environment
making sure we've got a culture that
that actually means it's a can-do
culture
um behaviorally
um we need to get to a point where we
get discretionary effort out of
everybody on the contract and people are
proud to work for uh for Trafford and
the one Trafford partnership and
realistically what we're trying to do
with this is to make sure that the
monitoring is in place that we can so we
can see performance we can head off
performance issues before they become
big issues
great transparency
um you'll you'll notice transparency in
this all the way through even to the
point of open book accounting we're
trying to get to work get to a point
where we can actually see performance
figures as they happen
um this applies to not just not just
service outputs but also in terms of how
we utilize Capital how we utilize
Revenue spend and making sure that when
we come because we we came to to this
particular room and talks about the high
amp and about how the high amp works and
about how the um uh how uh we can
utilize data to see just exactly how
much we need to spend on the road well
realistically we also need to need to
spend it properly and this data allows
us to actually measure that
so what do we want to get it from it
improve monitoring the service delivery
great transparency great better
management and service performance
earlier identification response to
service issues and effectively a better
customer experience is where we is is
what we're trying to I have not just
missed stealth member engagement it's
all about making sure that our
communication with everybody is but is
better
um
to do that we need we need the CMS
system to work as well but realistically
this is about putting the building
blocks behind it to make sure that make
sure we do that now the reports on a
regular basis which will give us the
stats that you will want on a regular on
a regular basis and that's all been put
in place thanks to this uh thanks to
this process
I promise you they're not all going to
be green slides so
the um the waste part of it waste was a
particular issue Helen's uh Helen's the
head of service for uh for waste and she
said will uh will help me answer any any
questions on this on this particular uh
thorny subject
um we needed to improve service
standards that was not something we'd
ever shied away from it needed to be it
needed to be done some of the changes
that we've made in the last few years
have facilitated where we've got to the
particular change of uh of areas for
Bing Crews while painful while it went
while it went on actually is
facilitating it facilitated it to the
amount that we have been Crews now
supporting each other in areas
we did a further change to the uh to the
Vincent to the bin service which is
which is tweaked that
but actually what we've also got uh the
it systems behind it uh to uh to
actually allow us to now make sure that
we've got big crew supporting each other
with the data fed part and you'll get
fed up and we can't be talking about
data but the world is where it is at
this moment in time I'm afraid you know
and we have to utilize the computer
systems to make sure that we can send uh
send Bing Crews back when they miss
something so we get that kind of
behavioral behavioral pattern where
we're finishing what we start and we're
doing it first time and that's and
that's something that I think people can
see that that's actually started to
happen
um
two issues uh with where one of the big
issues that coming along is the waste uh
waste minimization policy uh which is uh
which which is coming along with we
don't Market what we know a bit about
what's in that water but where where
we've where we've got to go for it as a
council is to actually maximize the
amount of the amount of recycling that
we do
to that effect with two P two members of
Staff back from Amy that have joined
Helen's team to look at ways to to look
at waste minimization to look at uh at
projects for the future that hopefully
that hopefully we'll uh we'll bring that
we'll bring that recycling rate up we've
got an okay recycling rate for
Manchester
um for greater Manchester but
realistically we can do better so and
that's the uh and that's the idea of
that
um we've got two smaller changes in
there which is about Christmas
collections to bring us in line with uh
with what happens within
um greater Manchester and make sure we
don't have issues around utilizing Crews
prior to Christmas which I know are
really annoys a lot of our customers if
we have to do that especially when
Christmas is in the is in midweek so by
cutting a green collection within the
within that Christmas week period where
we pick up the least amount of green
waste we actually give ourselves an
element of an element of staff to be
able to complete the Christmas
collections within three days
so in effect it means that we can
complete the important things for people
in that Christmas that Christmas week
when they want it done
um in terms of charges for larger grade
bins there is a loophole at this moment
in time with larger gray bins and that
is there too that is there to close that
particular loophole answer any questions
on that that people that people have
later on
the other part of it is CCTV coverage
each one of our vehicles is covered by
four CCTV cameras and making sure that
we are legally compliant with those with
new legislation that's coming to uh
so what's happening round balancing was
the was the last major change that we we
made to the uh um to the rounds in
February 23. it moved uh it moved an
element of rounds from certain areas of
the south of the borough to uh to
basically iron out a a particular issue
um that was raised by Dave Morgan the uh
the ex our ex Shadow exec member
and I'm basically making sure that we've
got a uh
um we've got a a Level Playing Field if
you like for each of the big Crews
through the week yeah through the week
so that we are producing the same amount
through the week and we didn't have any
Peaks and troughs or as many as are
flattening it as much as we possibly can
the computer systems about passing Miss
bins back to the cruise which was the
the behavioral issue that I mentioned
before crew targets and monitoring we
are now able to see what the crew
targets are and what and whether they
achieve it
proposals for roads with continual
access issues one of the biggest things
that we get is small areas where they
where there are parking restrictions and
whichever time the Bing crew gets there
determines whether it gets in or not
because people are either parts or
they're not and changes to that have
happened so it happened since the
pandemic with with more working from
home
um and actually looking at uh looking at
um how we how we how we deal with our
cons our capacities of containers will
continue to be uh be ongoing we also
have a future issue that we have areas
in the in Trafford which will have more
flats and more uh more high-rise
residential and how we've actually raise
the raise the recycling rates in those
is a challenge and uh and basically what
we what we do need to do is uh or we
have put together a project team with
Amy to uh to actually start to start to
look at how we how we how we challenge
them
and the last bit is the is the graph
um
why is analyze a statistics
but realistically we have seen
uh a kpi performance rise from uh from
June 22 which was on the deer to uh to
basically where we uh uh where we stand
today
I'll always say are we perfect no we're
not nowhere near and I will never ever
ever say that are we better than we were
yeah is there is this is there some
improvement that we can do yes there is
without
but in terms of complaints they've come
down
which is good
but we'll only be happy with the zero so
uh so that's the uh that that's the
that's the Target that we need to aim
for
um but we can see that the there is a
there is a movement through the through
that GS2 where
um to actually come down which is which
is great to see
playing performance mechanism uh when
the when the um contract was set up in
terms of kpis um because it is such a
broad contract some areas I think were a
little bit more overserved than others
it's probably the better way of putting
it I think what we want to do with this
is just to make sure that the balance
and coverage of the kpis which are our
main mechanism of incentivizing the
contractor are more evenly spread
within that there'll be uh a bit of a
well more focus on customer service
also a push towards uh towards basically
making sure that if we do have a problem
area in the contract that is not
currently served by a kpi we can make a
management PR which does not have a
financial penalty against it against it
for a period of time a year and then
should they fail that Target that can
move into a kpi to provide a more fiscal
fiscal incentive it gives us the
opportunity to obviously hit hotspots as
they change it's what I said right at
the beginning how do we make it fit for
purpose to move it to move on and make
sure that there is
the partnership but with an element an
element of uh of control that we need we
need within the contract
again in terms of the uh in terms in
terms of this kpis they are they are
published every year but we want to make
that more accessible for people as well
and to make sure that there is a there
is there is a robust annual review so
that we can change that and we've got
that that ability to flex the contracts
as as we move through and times change
yeah I mean this this States most and
there's a little bit more information
around it uh with uh with with kind of
kind of where we were it states about
the amendments to kpi descriptions and
uh and the it goes into a little bit
more detail about the MPI which is the
the um performance indicator without uh
monetary a monetary Target on it and
moving that MPI into a into a kpi
effectively when it's fairly it
encourages that right to write
first-time Behavior because if it
doesn't
move and it doesn't change back into it
then there is that penalty penalty down
the line which is uh which is which is
kind of where we needed to be
um
a few mpis that we've put in customer
cares and Care One Number of stage one
and and two complaints can we drive that
down that's that's one of the that's one
of the first ones that we've put in
waste the number of Miss bins per
hundred thousand hundred thousand so
again just sharpening the shouting in
the pencil on the pencil on waist and
making sure we've got a uh uh we've got
a view on that at highways just
maintaining the quality of address and
Street data at National Standard making
sure that we're still at Gold Standard
that we that we need to be is one of one
of our key bits
so
um realistically
the bottom bit most important how we
communicate it getting it getting some
of those some of those kpis oh we're
going all the kpis out there so other
people can see and actually they can get
a
um a feeling you know and an
appreciation of some of the things that
are happening within the contract and
how they're being held to account
systems this was one of the uh on the
one of the biggest parts of what we've
done I think came across from from the
waste part of it hopefully uh hopefully
but it's not on its own there have been
investments in quite a few sections the
next slide
um takes you can take you through some
of those investments in the in the
computer systems and how we're using
them
computer systems are great they've never
fixed anything on their own though so so
realistically it's about how we work
with them and actually make sure we make
sure we are utilizing the data properly
and actually making sure that we uh that
we've we've got the right
um
the right decision making off that data
to uh to to allow us to kind of get rid
of complaints quicker which is uh which
is the best thing I I often we talk
about stage one and stage two complaints
my ambition is to have stage zero
complaints where they don't arrive in
the first place
um that might you know it might seem
like a pipe dream to people but it's not
it should be what we what we do what
we're doing first and better information
up front
actually means that hopefully people
that people will understand why we make
certain decisions that we do that we do
some of those uh some of those systems
of data and data bits are on are on here
the first way the first one was probably
one of the biggest ones which was the
white space which allowed in-cab
technology so
effectively the the big crews could see
uh what they'd missed and they were sent
back to deal with those to deal with
those issues that they'd Miss themselves
the computer allowed a behavioral a
behavioral approach if you like because
funnily enough with us with a stable
amount of amount of staff that are used
to uh that are used to basically the um
uh the round that they're doing
they're more likely to have that root
knowledge but also with a computer
system to back that up then that should
bring down our Miss bins should bring
down our mysticistic Collections and so
on and so forth which we've seen and
they've seen on the graph so the
computer system helps but it's helping a
behavior and that's what we're that's
what we're trying to trying to uh to
drive
iCloud and handheld technology for FM
making sure that we we can we can
collect data quickly from uh from the FM
properties that we've got
similar confirmed work Zone which is uh
which is a system system for highways
and stream lighting which allows us to
take photographs it allows us to uh to
to have data at our fingertips for
issues that are issues that are brought
back not just from the inspectors but
also as people as people um request
things for service
we're going to roll out white space for
um Street cleansing that's actually
going on at this moment in time so uh so
basically we have a uh we have
um the same amount of data that we can
that we can drive from the street
cleansing people so we can see just
exactly where we've cleaned it it's
cleaned and what and um and actually
have some evidence-based evidence base
around that
and in terms of white space again uh for
grounds maintenance so uh so uh where
have we moan were the um which bits of
weed spraying etc etc we can but we can
build in there uh to uh to actually make
sure that we can we cannot we we know
what we've done we know when we've done
it and we can prove it and we can also
we can also
um make sure that we can make some
changes going forward to make sure
that's more efficient
decarbonization
um
as I said right at the beginning
seven years ago
um this wasn't built into the contract
um my location now in terms of in terms
of where in terms of where we are
um so this was a real push to try and
get the decarbonization agenda in that
making sure that we have a joint
commitment to substantively reduce the
carbon footprint because we do use
28 probably 29 when they're 29 on uh on
a push our CVS which burn a lot of fuel
and we have a big death but we put down
um we use carbon-based materials in in
what we do
uh and it's making it certainly within
within resurfacing Etc and it's how we
can look at the next stage of actually
trying to uh trying to bring all of
those down
not just materials but actually in terms
of usage and we've we've seen some
changes which which I've got on the next
slide about what's actually happened
um and a green Baseline measure for uh
for us both uh which will uh which will
tie into the uh to the council's targets
um and making sure that we have carbon
reduction projects and teams given the
time to look at those carbon reduction
projects be it within highways be it
within green spaces be it within the
within waste obviously within waste
there's a there's a big Target for
recycling
um but it's also about how we do the uh
the services and how we can bring that
down it's not quite as simple as let's
repeat let's replace all of the rcvs
with electric electric trucks but on
seven year leases we have to basically
build in it building
um changes in technology
um areas have done it for uh for for a
period of time we need to soak up some
of that learning that's uh from uh from
those those are the places that have
done and then find the right solution
for the uh for uh for what we've done
have we started yes
um in terms of roadmap
um we have
um quite a few working groups I'll pick
the I'll pick the highlights
Fleet Management is an obvious one
decarbonization working groups how we
can do things better
um looking at our buildings and sites
how can we do things around there not
including not including things like
solar not excluding things like like
Street lighting technology that we can
change
how we look um implementing carbon
calculation Accounting Standards so so
we kind of get a uh get get a
a view across both the public and the
private and the private sector sector
view that's uh that's actually actually
the same because there are numerous ways
of counting carbon at this moment in
time as we find out
uh making sure that uh making sure we've
got a um in terms of biodiversity that
we've got projects to to do that and
utilizing some of the uh the Amy free
days that they that they get for uh for
those who actually do to actually
support some of the biodiversity uh um
uh projects that we've got going on
Technology Innovation making sure that
we tap into what is quite a big
um kind of I think it's a huge company
in terms of in terms of Amy making sure
that we can tap into best practice in
all sorts of Industries to make sure we
can uh we can pull that into into what
we do in Trafford
instead of what we've done
at the moment we've got some uh Alpha
311 wind turbines turbines at um a
couple of trial sites that we uh um
we're looking at wind generated energy
for some of our size
of the electric vehicles
um all of Amy's Vehicles will be
exceptional rcvs are trying to be moved
towards uh towards
um electric models all of the company
cars uh phase to hybrid all the asbestos
cars are now electric so you might have
seen the little um the little one
traffic Cask kind of zipping around the
things while they're all electric now
which is great
EV Transit Vans for emergencies and
grounds are just coming in so uh so even
the even when we're going looking after
accidents and issues that have issues
that have happened that'll be done
hopefully on a decarbonized way a
decarbonization plan for The Deco uh to
look at uh solar possibilities and
things that things that we can do on
what is a big site
um RCV options
um well what I've just mentioned so in
other words what is the right option
there are two or three at this moment in
time
um but uh but we don't we we do want to
be on the right side of history when it
comes to when it comes to that with
betamax Etc we want to be the one that's
the one that's powerful enough to uh uh
to to move it and even some of the
electric options at this moment still
rely still rely on a diesel engine to
actually move the Good Winds at the back
so uh so some realistically we've got to
pick the right option
EV charging points at this moment in
time we're leading greater Manchester in
the uh in uh EV charging points doesn't
mean it's enough it's um to uh to head
off what will be a question I'm fairly
sure
um but we uh but realistically
we are looking at alternative Solutions
as well then the one that we've got that
we've gone now we've got and we've we're
hitting the saturation point with our
with our car Parks it's now what other
Technologies can be can we utilized so
we're looking at Liverpool what they're
doing what they're doing with the street
lights a bit of an issue front of the
plate in front of the foot way to the
back of the Footwear which always cause
the tripping issue but there are other
there are other Technologies out there
that we're looking to looking to trial
within the within the area
um we've got our solar powered street
lights
might be enough for me to people but
actually why not
um we've got uh yes a very limited
number and number in to see how they go
um at uh Woodbridge Road in Edmonton
well the first ones we first one was
ones we've put in
and of course the street lighting what
we're doing with the trimming and
dimming program so uh someone as always
reducing the Lux levels which in
a straight in times with uh with
electric electricity prices being
certainly where they were actually makes
complete sense from a fiscal point of
view and complete sense from a cargo
point of view so uh so the LED street
lights have allowed us you know the LED
project that was a few years old now
actually has allowed us to kind of
control that and we're moving what we
can to uh to LED as we as as we go
through our program
green spaces I think green spaces is uh
it's probably kind of one of the one of
the ones where we've got to be a bit
introspective about this because because
I don't think we
um we need to we need to look at our
strategy as a whole I think in terms of
in terms of how we put Capital into into
green spaces and this will be quite a
council-centric one as well as just
aiming I think there's I think Amy was
there's an elements a bit of did we are
we telling people what we've done and
when we were going to do things uh I
think the answer to that was probably a
no and what we're going to do is
straight is change that so I think
there's there's been
um plans now that have uh that have
appeared across uh across the various
websites but we're also going out to
friends at friends of arts groups and
giving them giving them the information
about what we can do in terms of the
service which has been affected by
fiscal issues fiscal issues over the uh
over over the last seven years but
actually stating what we can do and then
working with the friends of Parts Group
to get better results and I think that's
the uh that's the absolute key for this
we don't have a lot of capital to spend
with in green spaces so we've got to
spend it very wisely for making it
making sure that we do that in
conjunction with the people who are
people who care about the uh about the
parks that they uh that they look after
as well
um is the way forward and I'm making
sure we have that connection with our
with the uh with with the friends of
parks
um
some of this in terms of the month of
reports are now in place so we can see
what people have actually what we've
actually done in terms of these places
so we can actually actually report to
the Friends of parks and also anybody
else who's interested in the in the
number of parks that we've got we
maintain the 11
um green flags this year and it becomes
a strength every year to uh to do it but
what we um but we've managed to maintain
that through the pandemic period and
after which is which is really good news
and if we can we'll we we would like to
go further but um but really what we've
got to do at first at first is actually
be realistic we want with what we've got
and make sure that the information and
communication with the uh with the
friends of parks is is good and
hopefully you'll see from some of the uh
some of the examples there that we've
started to to move down that line it
also has a tie in with the
decarbonization bit about what different
things we can do in those friends of
parks such as Wilding kind of kind of
various bits
um or various different initiatives that
we can that we can take for
Capital
um
I think I mentioned at the start in
terms of uh in terms of of making sure
that we uh making sure we have the right
amount of balance in the balance in the
contract contract was based around an
amount of capital that went into the
into the contract that backed up the
amount of Revenue
what we've got to do within that within
this is to make sure that there is a
um that we're both aligned if you like
Amy and ourselves to make sure that we
get the best result for Trafford which
is making sure that that contract is
protected from a revenue point of view
but also
if we are actually attracting Capital
into the into uh the contract that we're
actually getting Capital spent within
the environs of Trafford one of my
commitments one of my absolute
objectives here is to is to basically
make sure that we we get
um our share preferably even more a
great of the the money that's given for
the devolved devolved government in
Greater Manchester because this is a
great area of Manchester and we want to
make it want to make it better some of
that is the active travel
some of it is uh some of it is um is
based around uh it's based around the
crsds monies that we get in but we have
a lot of projects that we are trying to
start within the within um within this
and we we have to have a contractual
mechanism that supports it and within
that making sure that there's a gain
share Arrangement that uh that allows us
to allows us if we go into a point where
we have more capital and we're
attracting more capital in from uh from
external Trafford traffic areas that
basically traffic Council get a
proportion of that to make sure that we
can keep our services in
um whole during what is a very pressured
time for finances so that's one of the
one of those bits so it's an
incentivization mechanism to make sure
that Amy are in Center incentivize to
win uh to win more work we're
incentivized to help them win more work
we have a value for money system in
place to make sure that they are they
are performed I mean within that but
also then that there that advantage that
we get from doing that is properly fed
down into the contract and that's one of
the one of the key parts of keeping us
open
so where are we on that Journey
in terms of capital projects capital
projects
um we mentioned that the the team are
grown
um or we mentioned oh Steve mentioned
that the uh that we got a uh more of a
um a management team in place we have
it's not just the uh two people that
were tupid into Helen's team around
waste we've also grown a projects team
so a Project's team with three
individuals who's uh whose job is
basically to make sure that we deliver
value for money
but we deliver more of uh of the of um
Capital uh Capital
um that's actually available to us some
of that a lot of that will be active
travel hopefully in the in uh in and
across Trafford but um but realistically
we've now got a um a larger team to be
able to make sure that we get exactly
what we want
um that most of the most of the first
part of it is Horizon scanning making
sure that we know where money is
available when it isn't when it is
available having the having kind of the
air if you like if you like all the time
to actually make sure that we can we can
spot the spot the funding opportunities
before they come and make sure that
we've got the time to secure them
then we can work on what we're on on
actually how we spend it
um
on active travel
um T1 and T2 tfgm funding of approvals
in May a bit of Gobbledy Ute that what
we actually mean by that is is basically
uh three
um quite large
um
Cyclops Junctions with it on Talbot road
that will feed into into a project uh of
making of being able to get a 12 year
old
on a on a bike from at the moment the
motorway to uh Motorway into Manchester
but but uh but eventually further on
further on and from from Ultram if we
can if we can do it not all of it will
take place on the a56
um but some of it will do as it's as
it's our major arterial arterial route
so as part of that kind of ambition
there is uh there is there are basically
um three projects there's uh one which
is going to come to uh come to uh
fruition in the next few weeks which
will be the south end of the uh uh the
south end of the a56 between the uh
between the Junctions
um of Talbot Road and the motorway and
also these two three cyclop Junction I
should say I should say on on Talbot
road which will which will hopefully
um support the existing cycleways around
it and make it safer for cyclists
cyclists and traversing those Junctions
um Green Space funding for Green Space
funding has been one of the
it's it's very small amounts of funding
but it means a lot to the people who
were people who were who need it so it's
making sure that we have control of that
green space funding and making sure that
we spend it in the right place for
instance the swings in Parks it's it's
small small amounts of money but it has
to be spent well
um the a56 project delivery so moving
back on myself but uh but basically the
the top end of the year of uh Talbot
Road was almost a proof I think in this
in this
um in this period that we've moved into
that project delivery phase where we can
actually get things on the ground and
often people agree that so that's
actually quite a nice scheme that it
runs uh that runs from the border uh
cornbrook uh further down towards the uh
towards the end of the A5 104.
ambition is everything isn't it but uh
but we've got quite strong Ambitions
around the earthstone active
neighborhood which is uh which um we're
working towards towards the solution
with tfgm to uh to try and build part of
it's a big big project we went out to
Capital to work to consultation and got
18 million pounds worth of suggestions
which would have been great if we had 18
million pounds
um but what we've uh what we've got to
do is cut our cloth slightly so what
we've got to make sure is that we
deliver elements of elements of it and
work towards that 80 million pounds
total as money in money is made is made
available and at least that gives us a
stock of projects that we that we can
deliver
the a56 north Corridor
um
I think we've probably you've heard too
much about that but effectively trying
to get that 12 year old to to the uh to
the bit and and how it continues down
through sale and making sure that Ultra
Ultra has brought into it as well and
also the greenway which is uh which
which is on there so there's there's a
lot to go out
but we've got to be ambitious so so if
we're ambitious and we've got the team
to uh to start delivering and we've got
the uh got the
um
we've got the will from Amy to do it as
well then hopefully that provides a
potent mix in terms of in terms of what
we can actually deliver in the next
seven years
so you'll be glad to know into the
overall summary
um
there's a commitment to improving the
delivery of the OTP we are where we are
we're stable at this moment in time I
think I can I think I can say that
um the point is though that everything
that I've said about data stability
about
um Workforce stability management
stability leads us to a point where you
can actually start to push on
um yeah the one Trafford partnership
says it kind of says it on the tin it
was a partnership so what we try to do
is to bring it back into that into into
the mainship meaning meaning of that
word and try and move it and try and
move it on in terms of delivery
with the greatest and ongoing cyclical
review process so in other words the
opportunities that are that are there we
can we can look at
um jointly and we can make sure that we
can we can we can look at any changes to
the uh changes the organizer changes to
um mostly digital kind of kind of issues
that could come up that come along that
can make us more efficient or can put
more things onto the roads into the into
the Waste Service than we've ever done
before
and of course our job as a team is to
monitor it closely and just make sure we
have value for money and make sure we
get what it says on the tip
benefits of the changes it fits the
changes the residents are Trafford
well we've achieved a platform that's
better that people have noticed
um but again I'll stress it until the
cows come home it's stable it's not
brilliant you know so so what we what we
do need to do is to kind of keep that
keep that continuous Improvement going
earlier identity identification and
response to service issues
if we've got an issue we need to spot it
earlier preferably before it happens and
preferable but preferably before anybody
else spots it
um or maybe even not have them in the
first place but to do that we need the
information and we need the and we need
a an attitude of sharing if you like
between between the parties
better customer service is a given
making sure our communication is better
making sure that the the experience of
engaging with one traffic partnership is
better than it's been before
don't think we're there yet I think the
CR the CRM system will have to come in
play into play when that when that
changes
um but what I can say is that we've now
got the right information to feed into
that CRM system to allow us to make some
of those some of those changes going
forward
greater transparency
is something that was a given at the
start of this we wanted to know more
about what we were doing
how much we were doing doing it for when
we were failing and what we could do
about it
improved governments governance making
sure that we have the metis structures
and the and the data coming back out of
the service to know when we were failing
and do something about it
investment in the ltp making sure that
the money and the fiscal part of it was
Secure on that we had the ability to go
and find more investment to put into the
highways and put into the airport to
Green spaces and supporting the waste
service for uh for this uh for this
Borough
and also and it shouldn't be at the
bottom to be for making sure that our
environmental impact from what is a very
impactful service in terms of what we do
we play with tarmac we look at recycling
the recycling rates we tidy away
people's waste not only from the street
from from people's yards from the from
the uh from the streets as well so we
have to be better about what we do
because we are the Forefront of that we
have the buildings so
thank you
we'll be putting an exec um an executive
report through in September uh this uh
this basically is gives delegated
authority to complete the negotiations
which uh which is as we see a fairly uh
fairly close to fruition
um hopefully people will know the
progress mate
um again I want to I just want to want
to stay it's not the light switch
uh this has been going for a while
um and
if it was a light switch it would then
stay light but realistically where's the
Improvement
uh this is a it's a graph that's going
that's hopefully going like that and
people can see what we've got to do is
we've got to put work almost harder to
make sure that we we get up the get up
the next stage of that
and uh basically
um no one agree the proposed time sales
which is to finish in September and
continue the continued investment into
the OTP and the potential for further
continuous improve
mostly agree changes in there I wouldn't
be telling you about grass going in the
right direction if if we haven't put
some of it in place and you can see that
um that we've done so we need to
conclude conclude the final negotiations
with Amy document the data variation and
submit that executive report
next part after that is how we get
better after it so thanks for listening
I know the answer to this but are there
any questions
well thanks for that to Chris
um obviously there's a lot of detail in
there
um and what I'll do now is open in the
up for questions
any questions
counselor Coggins
thank you and thanks uh Chris and the
team for a very detailed report
um I had a few different questions
um
the carbon neutral action plan isn't
mentioned at any point I know that Amy's
um targets are uh 24 keywords the gmca
one is 2038
um and
um
offsetting is mentioned as a last resort
my understanding of Amy's position on
offsetting is that they want an 80
reduction on 2019 without offsetting
obviously 20 is still quite a bit and so
I'm wondering how we deal with the
differences between our carbon reduction
targets and theirs and that was one
question
um I was also interested in a mention of
the 2ping of the waste minimization team
perhaps Helen could give us some
clarification we didn't get anything on
that in the in the presentation it was
just it's in the notes there briefly
um on the cars I see the EV cars and
hybrids obviously welcome there's no
mention of reducing car use moving to
East scooters electric bikes anything
like that obviously traffic's quite a
small area electric cargo bikes things
like that obviously I'm not suggesting
we do the bins by bike Bush that there
are perhaps things we can do and as I
say
um what we can't be aiming for is to
just replace all our existing congestion
with electric congestion we need to be
aiming to change how we're working
um I'll I'll leave it at that Fern oh
yeah sorry and last just pure
clarification this contract started 2015
in Sunrise and the 23 years then take to
23 is 50. it's 15 but with the option to
continue so it takes us to 2030.
so really The Seven Year review we are
now eight years in with seven years to
go he's all right just to clarify thanks
I think it would probably be better to
call it a mid-contract review
semantics but that's what it's called in
the uh called in the documentation just
once a while
um I think the
it is quite challenging in terms of the
carbon neutral plums to to align public
and private
um and I know I know your comments on
that because we will we will actually
look into look into that I think what we
were trying to do was to make sure our
plan to the end of the contract actually
uh actually dovetailed in with each
other that we had uh physical projects
that we we could do that would actually
make a difference within Trafford so the
offsetting
um we're not there's nothing in terms of
the offsetting Target that we would put
in the decarbonization in the air that
would that would include offsetting
we're looking at actual practical
differences so we're practical ways of
taking carbon out so we would not for
instance keep a an RCV and and put uh
put off setting into that that would not
be something would be like be looking at
doing
in terms of 2038 2014 2040 Target and
the uh and the
um the direction of travel if you like
um that our extra travel is over the
next seven years really it's
realistically to 2030. so taking that
we're going to use our figures in terms
of in terms of where where we are to to
make sure that that is uh that that's
that's carried through and looking at
the uh looking at the the ways that uh
ways that uh both their their way of
capturing carbon in our way of capturing
carbon actually one of the uh one of the
differences is that they are actually
starting to look at uh look at how we
capture material carbon or carbons in
material which is actually something
that we're not looking at actually this
moment in time so realistically between
the two there there may actually be
quite a lot hopefully a better saving so
we're so we we actually we're not we're
not looking at how we encapsulate
um uh carbon within concrete for
instance or within or within some of the
some of the actual materials we're using
and actually that's actually now
influencing how we hit how we capture
the capture the carbon which is uh which
is actually quite interesting and
provide that provoked quite a lot of
discussion uh it's uh one of our meters
meters recently this is embedded carbon
rather than capturing carbon capturing
carbons are different yeah
um so I think yes it's difficult
um but the good news is that both
parties really do are committed to
actually to actually moving it on or
what I want is I want to plan for the
contract that actually takes us to a to
an agreed to a agreed solution in terms
of the amount of carbon that we put out
with a measurable amount that we can uh
that we could actually actually put out
either within the report or within the
within the final within the final
agreement document that we do
um yeah so we've um transferred two
members of staff to my team um
I think quite a few of you will have
sent them out and about talking to
Residents and trying to change behavior
in our reorganization last year of the
team I've actually got two more
positions in that team so I'm gonna have
a team of four
um waste minimization officers that will
be
their focus is what it says to reduce
the amount of waste that households are
producing in Trafford and so
um they've already made a really good
start while they're at eight while they
were about Amy
um and our waste Horizons has come down
significantly last year and I'm hoping
that just the figures aren't audited yet
but as soon as they are we will be
making a big song and dance about that
because the recycling boat hasn't
improved but the residual waste has come
down significantly when we look at per
households so yeah there's a lot there's
lots of projects that they're going to
be working on
um we're just working with them to look
at the next 12 months and we will be
talking to councilors about what we're
doing in different areas so yeah if
you've got any ideas
please come and talk to us likewise
we'll do the same just that there's
actually a third person as well but
obviously never linked to the Estates
Department they've been transfer super
dope wasn't there oh a business support
well yeah so that's not part of that
team but that they were teach over at
the same time it made sense to do that
so they're actually working on the
client team now as well
and within escapes
Council of facts thank you
tiny little bit on the last bit
um what we have done as well is because
the Island's here has had a service and
that's one of the uh one of the biggest
points because we've now moved to two
heads of service recognizing that the
recycling rate is one of the key parts
of what we're what we're doing and it
needs that recognition
um so the 2p part of it is only one one
bit of a of a of a full record a full
full reorganization uh to be fair that
has seen us take take in in that part as
well as the as well as the projects uh
projects bit that we're doing which is
focused on active travel so there's
quite a quite a quite a skew if you like
in terms of the team towards uh towards
um the decarbonization agenda
um the last one in terms of uh in terms
of utilizing utilizing cargo bikes and
so on we've not looked at that in in
massive massive depth but what we have
done in terms of the terms of projects
projects around decarbonizing
um a lot of our a lot of our activities
I went to see last week
um the first electric small Digger that
we've got so uh so basically for the
works that we're works that we're doing
out on uh out on site in terms of small
scale drop curbs and so on we now have
two electric uh two electric diggers so
that takes away a lot of the fuel from
that probably the biggest move that
we've done is our move towards
um non-uh non-fossil fuel hand tools
um I know people probably don't
appreciate it but but the racket that we
produce when we're when we're doing it
it's mostly caused by an engine on a
still saw or a uh or or the peckers that
we that we use and again on um again
last week we actually saw one of the
first electric uh electric still Source
being used and the first electric
um uh uh electric packaging to be fair
to Amy that is part of their kind of
kind of assessment of what they can do
not only from an mfp because there are
actually a couple of other spin-offs yes
they're more expensive but uh but
actually the spin-offs are not just for
the environment they're also for the men
themselves because the haves use in
terms of uh in terms of their hands is
reduced but also as you may as you as
you mentioned the sound that uh that
that people are that people are going
through while they're working for us uh
is uh is obviously an issue so it's
really it's really good actually to go
out and see some of these initiatives
and we were hoping that both Street
lighting on the highways will be as
close to where close as they can
certainly in terms of the terms of the
operational part to carbon zero as they
can be by the end of next year
cargo bikes are next
Council
yeah hi thanks Joe
um I hear we've been saying Chris about
stability not Perfection
um and listening to what we're saying
just now about attitudes of sharing and
transparency
um and better service delivery so
perhaps uh this might be interesting to
know my colleagues have been speaking to
some of the front line Crews from the
lnq from the housing associations what
used to be trafficked Housing Trust
alongside the residents that live in a
lot of those tht properties they're
reporting real issues actually with Bing
collections at multiple occupancy sites
and perhaps we could have spoken a bit
more about that just now
um in terms of data and numbers in the
last Financial year Trafford housing
trusts that is to sale in queue have
told us they've collected
288 tons of waste from properties in
Trafford that have been neglected by Amy
communal bin stalls are regularly not
collected or they're not Collective
property lockable bins like the ones
that you know you put bottles in or
something and they're not they're left
unlocked so they then get abused
you know these are housing associations
they're not waste management Specialists
and it's 288 tons so maybe someone's
left an extra bag by the bin store yeah
so the whole lot's ignored so then you
know you've got a full communal bin 10
or 12 properties still generating waste
another week goes by you've now got a
mountain you've got health and safety
problems you've got Crews saying at this
point we get called Amy are saying we
can't send our staff to that you know
the Housing Association have to clean it
up so I think the sort of questions we
should be asking ourselves
is would any of us like to look out of
our window an overflowing bin store with
rats when we've just been re-homed in
social housing the bottom line is
somewhere in Amy I'm afraid there is not
the can-do attitude it's an overzealous
attitude to rejecting bins one person
has left a bag by the side the bin the
whole block gets ignored I've been told
by the housing associations you've got a
spin at the end of the street with a
sticker on from last week because it's
contaminated it's a social housing
Street the whole Street's ignored
because there's house number three has
got a sticker the Lorry can't get past
the park cars on the Narrow Street with
the old folks in the sheltered housing
so they haven't had the bins emptied for
weeks
I'm sorry it's not a can-do attitude
there's just this culture of trying to
avoid collecting difficult bins and I I
can't go back to them and say well we've
got new governance groups and let me
tell you about this I.T system can I
that that's not what they want to hear
so I I think it'd be useful to talk a
bit around that maybe communal
specifically in the housing associations
conversations with us because we have
regular engagement meetings with them
directly and we do have a working group
on Flats with lmq and regular site
visits with them so
um we know there are particular issues
with communal bins around contamination
and them filling bins with other items
that you know maybe should be a bulky
based collection and but we do have a
process with lnq where if there's a
problem and the crews reported to the
supervisor the supervisors call lmq all
the other management company straight
away and try to work with them to
resolve it and so if there is um
sideways which means that we can't get
to the bin if Allen Q remove the extra
waste Amy return at their cost you know
for an extra collection to then remove
the waste we do remove waste on
contaminated bins regularly at all costs
um so I think I think from our point of
view when we are trying to work with
management companies that's that's a bit
frustrating
um and it would have been nice to have
that you know have those conversations
earlier with them but we do have flats
project like we mentioned and a lot of
that is looking at how we can improve
the collections at Flats so how we can
prove access and work with management
companies to improve access to bin
stores which means that we can get in
safely and also residents can use them
safely so
um improving signage you know improving
monitoring of Bin stores so that when
bins are contaminated that's dealt with
their early intervention with the
residents so then when we arrive we've
been Crews that we can empty the bins
um if there is a street that's blocked
access we will return
you know regularly until we come and get
access and again that's at Amy's cost
for the extra Fuel and visit so
it's not that they're leaving them
intentionally although we do
um buy regular monitoring and looking at
the blocked access issues intervene with
Crews where they need extra support
extra training you know sometimes we get
a new driver that isn't as confident
access in the street that another driver
could do
um and so we do have a
um a way to intervene with that
um so that they can get that extra
support and that coaching because
sometimes it is just a confidence thing
when you're in a different area
um and then when we talked about the
um our new structure so I was the waste
manager I'm now the head of service I've
got a waste manager that reports to me
and that means that we've got the
capacity in the team to be more
proactive and working more closely with
ome on issues like this so
um the gentleman that works for me Avi
and he will be out on site meeting Crews
meeting supervisors and trying to look
at how we can resolve
those issues with Amy and you know some
in some cases we've put um
traffic regulation orders in so yellow
lines they're going through a process at
the moment there's lots of different
options that we're looking at so that
the repeat issues can you know can be
resolved longer term we don't want we
don't want those repeat issues we do
want them resolving
um so you know how how to contact us
um if there's anything that you know we
need to be working on come and talk to
us and we'll and we'll resolve it
I think it is a bit frustrating because
we do have a dialogue with uh with them
on a regular basis uh and certainly the
feedback of that figure has not been
represented to us
um there are issues with
um contamination of building bins we
have a clear policy on what that
contamination is
um if it's sort of being overzealously
um
enforced yeah then we will by all means
have a look at that and realistically
another cost difference between a
contaminate contaminated bin that we get
processed and the uh and the Nom is the
extremely high in terms of the waste
Levy
um like waste Levy numbers that we that
we put out in a year it is in excess of
15 million pounds if you pay for that
weight for that waste Levy which is
actually more than the revenue revenue
amount for the entire highways and waste
contract so realistically we do have to
um be quite robust when it comes to when
it comes to contaminated bins but we
also have to be aware that we've got to
do a lot of
um learning a lot of teaching a lot of a
lot of communication to make sure that
people know what contamination actually
is
we currently have I think how many uh
how many cros going through for
six or seven yeah so what so we're
looking at so we're looking at an option
for because we we know that the world
has actually changed in terms of where
people
where people work and unfortunately
their first their first thought is not
can we get the uh can we get the bin
crew in
um and what we did see was quite a spike
after the pandemic with people working
from home
obviously parking areas uh parking areas
are congested in uh in a lot of the
areas a lot of the areas that we've got
uh housing that was built in the 1920s
um or possibly even even before which
being honest didn't give um give enough
room to put one car in let alone two
which a lot of people have so uh so so
realistically that's what the uh that's
what the the crews are actually fighting
against on a regular basis
put him into put them into place uh
working for Helen is making is is going
to be there to you mentioned the
stability part right at the beginning
um what stability in any service allows
you to do is to get Crews more more
experience that the individual areas
that they're working in so at that point
that level of experience picks up they
know when to go to a street first off
when not to go to the street first off
because they do notice patterns so it's
to encourage that kind of that level of
behavior with uh with it and for Avi to
be able to work on by exception so in
other words take the exception to the
rule rather than the rule and uh and
resolve individual issues where we where
we've got them across the piece so that
would be uh that would be uh it would be
basically what we would be looking to do
in the next few years I'll just add to
that quickly obviously I've been
involved in a few of these uh visits to
some of these sites myself since I took
on the role initially I did find some
really strange things where traffic
Housing Trust as it was we're not
working with us so there's one case
where they actually built this bin store
in the middle of this circular car park
and out in the bin store was actually on
a pavement about this high and and these
shoes your bins you know so I mean that
that has changed now so they have been
working more a couple of others in
locating where they've been sourced to
actually go to the accessible for the
Bing Crews uh and also and obviously uh
hopefully as well for the residents as
well but it has been a real problem in
that sense but uh if there are issues as
I think as Chris Hammer said do contact
us I mean I've said to my own group that
where they're particularly ongoing
problems uh you know I can be copied
into messages as well and I'll discuss
them well well where intervention needs
to be made and I don't shy away from
that at all I'm quite Keen to get the
put we want to see the cooperation with
uh th2 or L and Q as they are now and
I'm working with them but uh part of
that as well is that isn't just about uh
also if that's uh Chris Evans outline
and it's also about actually moving
forward and actually doing more in the
way of encouraging people living in
those sort of flats and so forth to
actually learn about recycling more and
given opportunities to actually show
actually the benefits of it and that's
some of the big projects that we want to
do we have been taking under undertaking
some over the last couple of years and
it's certainly an area where we need to
expand a lot more into Flats but this it
is certainly a challenge but it's
certainly something has moved forward uh
certainly the government strategies will
be aiming at those sort of things where
we want really to increase these cycle
across the piece and I think Flats have
to be included in that and say uh adding
number Flats in other areas where
they've actually been writing to me
saying they want to recycle more the
company who built them didn't put in the
facilities for them so in some cases
there's the willingness there and others
we have to work with housing
associations to actually engage with
those tenants in there and actually
encourage them and give them some
support they need to actually do it and
find ways to actually help them to do it
so I think Chris has commented about the
uh access problems and and I do monitor
these uh every day myself I'll get the
accomplished emails and I see where
I see the hot spots where they actually
are and we're dealing with some of them
the crews themselves uh they deal this
number of ways they can actually put uh
like cards on cars that are blocking it
if there's continual problems they can
actually do letter drops to the houses
to say explain please can you keep this
clear on on the on collection day so
that looks of interest and I think the
last result we're doing is that we're
doing the uh these several of these uh
putting together into the worst hot
spots and and that will actually help
hopefully these in places like Junctions
in place where people simply Park in any
case but I mean we do accepts as Chris
Outland this has sort of a been a
problem more since the pandemic where
there's more people working from home
perhaps more likely as well to use the
car more socially than for work
interesting I did see a stat recently
that said that car ownership and
Trafford has gone down but obviously
people using their vehicles differently
in that sense so I think that there's
areas to do around that which is
possible I mean I'm quite happy to work
with them and say please do get in touch
with us and and make sure every single
thing is wrong with us because we aren't
aware of it it doesn't count and and
those problems will continue so we want
to work with everybody thank you
councilor win Stanley and then councilor
Oxford
ah thank you chair I was looking for
some reassurance around the the kpi
measures but just to say
um the approach brought here tonight has
been really refreshing it's been really
really open the what the officers and
what the executive member has said
um and the general approach to take into
this I think is is a very
um pragmatic one because there was
clearly something wrong with the
relationship between the council and Amy
and this is aiming to reset that
relationship but I mean I mean I've got
to say as Administration when we
inherited something which was well I'm
not going to go through the all the old
moans again except for the fact
self-monitored there was no open book on
anything completely opaque
um an absolutely confused kpis I don't
think when we first were took control
was I don't think it was possible to see
what it was we were supposed to be
delivering as a council and we're really
moving well towards addressing those but
the question itself is really around the
kpis themselves is that
um because what we want is award
counselors is for our inboxes to stop or
telling us about
stuff bins you know the the day-to-day
stuff and the key to that is going to be
the way you manage the the contract on a
rolling monthly basis so the question is
how soon if you if one of the kpisa is
on Bing collections start you you it
starts to drop off how soon before
that's jumped on by the management team
and an improvement produced end of the
month
end of the month is that quick so we
would expect you would expect to see
that Improvement in the following months
in terms of the so if it's an
established kpi although all our kpis
are measured month on month
um so where that wouldn't be the case is
if we hadn't got a kpi for it and that
was the mechanism that I was describing
with the MPI and I went into three
letter acronyms and disappear and so on
we all have a CLA Chris yeah absolutely
but in terms of in terms of the um if we
needed a new if something something was
failing that isn't being measured within
the contract that's where the mechanism
for putting a new kpi in actually comes
to fruition because we'd be able to set
an MPI around that Affair MPI no not a
not not a punitive one but a fair MPI to
get the performance back up if that
performance wasn't coming up for the new
thing whatever it may be then then
basically that would then after the year
become a kpi that there will be a
deduction as well so if it ever soon
exist you want something which is clear
they just will have the bin collections
that would be addressed in the same one
we'd expect award Council to see that
following month and we've got um
we've got examples I mean we track and
every year we have um we have a Tracker
which we're available to any Council by
the way if any situation the um we track
uh kpi performance for all of our all of
them my channels with uh does it within
the uh within the within my department
and uh and we get our graphs so if it
falls for instance one of the one of the
graphs that I put up on the screen was
the was the Miss bins so uh so looking
at that looking at the complaints levels
and we have
next to real-time information now it's a
month so we're sorry so it's not
answered the kpi but actually in terms
of this bins we actually have more or
less real-time information so while the
kpi will hold it to the week to the
month sorry uh actually Helen's team are
able now certainly within waste uh to in
to uh to look at the white space system
and see it on a daily basis so we can
actually see if there is a particular
issue with a clerk with a crew or there
is an issue not that not that it's it's
not meant to be punitive to the things
to to actually see where we've got
issues in geographically where we've got
issues with material with uh Machinery
because not everything that we do is
about the men it's all it's you know
it's it's in terms of spotting Trends in
terms of the terms of machine use and so
on and so forth we've got access to that
and on a
weekly basis you have a meeting with uh
have a meeting with your opposite number
within um uh within
um uh within the within the depot but
Avi realistically is working with them
so uh so actually uh when it comes to
something that is measurable through the
white space system with a computer
system there it should be solved within
the day
or we're watching a great interest thank
you if it gets to a point where the
weather kpi gets troubled then then
that is something that's something
systematic
um we're always going to get operational
problems there are always going to be
issues just after the first bank holiday
of the year where everybody wants to cut
their grass uh when it's absolutely
guaranteed that that's first that first
Frost in September where every tree in
the in the area decides to suddenly
deposit
36 000 tons of uh I don't think it was
that this year of of um of leaves onto
onto the onto the network we're always
going to get those issues
um and they're the operational issues
that we have to make we have to manage
on on a on a daily basis realistic
realistically though what we want to see
is that the average performance is going
like that and then we can head off some
of those uh some of those big issues
that uh that we know we'll get with
element Supply actually yeah
sorry you can understand one more thing
just so to see how the ideal is if we
raise something with the team then you
go yeah we know and I've got to say that
I've had a couple in the last few weeks
where that's actually happened where
we've raised here we know so yeah okay
yeah I feel I feel reassured I'd also
feel reassured that there's no
complacency at all coming out the team
is there because this is not a done deal
is it no fantastic thank you okay
um yeah I just wanted to ask about the
actual cost of carrying out the review
with those costs the council costs were
they met by Amy that was my first
question
um second one was about you mentioned a
little bit about the ongoing review
process will there be any kind of I
could see the day-to-day reviews will
there be any kind of overall kind of
review process so and also my last
question was
um looking at the you mentioned the
Improvement objective Accounts at the
beginning of the presentation are you
confident that
those Improvement objectives have been
achieved by by this review it sounds it
sounds like you are so I just wanted to
check those thank you
sorry what was the first one I apologize
first one was about the costs of
carrying out the review uh the custom in
half
to be fair because it was a contractual
uh contractual part part of the contract
so
um but in terms of the terms of actual
resources used
um one of the reasons why it's taken
quite a long time
is because we could bring in uh quite a
lot of expensive Consultants uh to uh to
help us with this and they will spend a
hell of a lot of time asking the people
who work on the contract what was
actually happening
um so in in the event we've actually
only employed one consultant uh to help
us and that's not been on a full-time
basis through this so it's been uh one
to two days to do those days a week so
actually allow us to allow us to kind of
almost take an introspective look at it
um and to take a uh to take a disengaged
look of what we were doing most of the
cost of cost of what we've done the
exception of the legal charges that
we'll have to do through through this
where Amy's legal charges will be met by
Amy and our legal charts will win that
by ourselves
um really realistically
um apart from apart from those
extraneous costs uh the cost has been in
time of the team
let's answer that question
um in terms of in terms of the review
um we would be looking to do a review of
uh performance in the in the contract we
do internal reviews monthly so each one
of the in the governance section of the
uh of the report and plus and plus what
what I said there is a monthly review a
monthly report that's issued by uh
issued by by any on every single service
in the contract now
so so that's reviewed by its opposite
number within there within my within my
team when I say it's reviewed we talk
through it to make sure to make sure
that those uh that uh that the the stats
are right but also that with because the
computer systems are open now
it's one sensored in one sense of the
truth I think
um where we were in the past is that you
spend quite a lot of time arguing what
the figure is rather than what to do
about it
um and the first thing the first thing
for me was to remove that if you can get
the openness right you know what the
problem is then the proper discussion
that's actually going to make things
right is about how you fix it and that
is the biggest the biggest thing that we
wanted to do was to make sure that the
information coming through was provable
that it was that it was accurate and it
was useful
um and it's the third one that makes the
difference and making sure that the the
managers within the team have the power
the delegated power to change elements
elements about elements about small
things within the contracts if we need
it if we need further changes to policy
and so on and so forth then it goes
through the normal channels but it's
those it's those um those meetings that
will bring that up in addition to that
we'll do an annual review to actually
make sure that anything that feeds back
back from all those that goes into the
kpis and the kpis need changing it's
caught at that particular that
particular Point realistically I would
expect it to be cut a long time before
it got to the annual in the annual
review but the government but the
governance governance allows for that
for that multi-stage process if that
answers that one
very quickly to that point as well so
obviously I did beginning exactly that
this isn't the end of the journey by any
means it's really one sense of it it
will be continuing and we do want to see
that Central achievement so we started
to see some improvements we're not there
yet of course obviously over the journey
over the next seven years we want to see
those figures climbing higher we can get
that uh improved performance and
actually also get with the finances that
Chris outlined in the report that'll
actually be key to actually driving like
this because if uh no Amy I've actually
started to invest in it which they
didn't obviously like the beginning that
that means obviously that we can then
get out of it the services that our
residents need and that's it and that's
what we key to it and that's what a lot
of things are missing at the beginning I
mean
uh I think members enjoyed the
presentation it's very fun I couldn't
comment on it was that much in it it's
actually huge so you can see uh in this
case I'm simply doing a seven year
review and so forth it's actually a huge
amount of work gone into it from Chris
and the team and everybody else uh
um the amount of times I've seen the
reports uh and presentations on it is
amazing but and when the exact reporters
come out I'm not sure it'll actually be
able to encapsulate the whole amount of
work that's going with it but you've got
a bit of capture on that from that
presentation tonight you can see uh it
may give you a better idea in some sense
rather than the exact report so
obviously we're keen to sort of see that
reflected where we can but obviously uh
it isn't just for councilors as well
today I want to see things like members
of the public and Community groups
actually uh perhaps at city that they
can actually understand this better as
well and actually uh and where we can
work with them to actually make changes
where they're actually needed but yeah
thank you
counselor Walsh
the question was um are you confident
that the Improvement objectives were met
and it sounds like you are so that's
just kind of like I'd never say that
yeah
it would be a breaking character
um do I feel that we did the whole thing
about the light switch I know I've
overplayed that analogy is absolutely
true it's a journey
um we're not there you know and and the
and and it would be
um silly of me to say we are what we are
is
um we've now I think gone through those
five those five major objectives on
there and I can see a road map to
success with the within those
um would I say we've met them I think
we've got the possibility of meeting
them now so end of the beginning there's
certain qualities one said thank you I
feel reassured thank you
Council Walsh
thanks chair
um is there an appetite to share this
review with the public
um I've done about the practicalities
about that I have to say Chris some of
the some of the um present slides are a
bit dry perhaps and I like the ones
where there's pictures and you know kind
of simple I'll put those in specially
for me to understand
[Music]
so you might want to change that that
detail but I just went about because I
do think the public do do want to know
and uh and they certainly know about
about the name Amy and just thinking
about that it you know it's it's the one
Trafford partnership that we've been
working with them for seven years now I
just wonder what would it have been
useful for them to been here this
evening you know I I would love to talk
to them Council Works closely with other
organizations and and they come in and
and Charters indeed come to scrutiny
meetings and the other on the third
issue I've got is just to what
possibilities they are are there around
commercial waste so you said there are
there's something that didn't
didn't turn up if that's the right way
as much as you thought at the beginning
is is that something you're going to
actively um pursue in the future
yeah I think um
I think I think the first thing is
um once this has gone through the um the
last stage of negotiation and we've got
a
um an out well I won't call it an
outcome we've got a path uh to uh to do
it then yes absolutely it shouldn't be
shared
um
it's become the one traffic partnership
um because of some of the failings has
become an element of utility brand so so
people I think felt it was felt it was
uh not delivering on what on what it was
doing
um a reputation is very easy to uh easy
to lose it's very hard to regain and uh
and what and what we what we do need to
do is to make sure
that we're saying ourselves targets
they're right that uh that are out in
the open so that people can see them uh
and are measured against those Target at
those targets which we shouldn't be
afraid of doing so uh so actually when
we do that that is the path to uh an
element an element of people uh people
are accepting accepting what what we've
got within the one traffic partnership
so I would say yes
um should Amy have been here I think
Chris would have liked to have been in
actually to be honest the uh the um
account director for uh for uh for uh
Amy's side of the ltp
um and we've got no problems with
incoming I think we did the we did the
high amp in here who's a member of Amy
was part of it
um realistically where you know what
what does good look like is it is one of
those one of the greatest kind of bits
what good looks like for me as you
shouldn't see the joint
yeah realistically you know the the blue
lanyard and the yellow lanyards should
be it should be a material because you
should be getting what you need to get
from the person
I mean there are there are fiscal issues
around the last seven minutes the last
seven years you know whereas
it's not not everything is uh is
basically down to Amy when it comes when
it comes to these things I think what
we've got what we've got to do is is
make sure that our communication is
better about some of the limitations
that uh that that they and does have to
work under but also that we strive to
get that customer service right and that
the answer is right I think at that
point uh people hopefully won't see the
gym
um in terms of Commercial Way social and
over to my permanently more qualified
yeah so in the original contract there
was a big push for growth on Commercial
waste Collections and with the um profit
share for the council
um and the reason that it didn't work it
was focused too much on
um big contracts generating lots of
income which also brought with them big
disposal costs because they were like
you know big
um you know companies producing lots of
waste basically
where we want to focus now is how um how
I would run a commercial race contract
if it was in-house which is around the
small local businesses of Trafford
making sure that we can provide them
with a good service which means that
they don't then don't voice in the
Alleyways they don't use the bins for
the flats above the shops they don't put
it in the litter bins and so it's yeah
all that so it's it's bringing it more
back to a local level we're in Trafford
every day of the week so we should be
able to provide a good service with a
small businesses
um and then
we want to look at the recycling side of
that we're hoping at some point we'll
get um some answers from government on
the resources and waste strategy and
what what they expect us to provide
um and then hopefully there will come
some funding streams with that which
will help us really expand that
commercial Waste Service because it's
not
um obviously that the businesses should
pay for that so it shouldn't cost us
money long term but there's just some
setup costs and you know
um
providing them with um support really to
help them separate the waste better and
recycle more so that's definitely
something that we will be looking at but
it's bringing that down to that local
level and improving the local
environment by providing a better
commercial based service that's how I
see it working
quickly on Chris's point about obviously
and yourself at some point uh the Amy
Van was seen as toxic out there I mean
ironically uh Amy do quite a lot of good
work as well I think Chris did outline a
little bit of it and you may have come
across from it yourselves in your own
Ward that they do lots but they don't
make enough of it and it doesn't get out
there and so I think uh really they want
to help address some of the uh some of
the concerns the public have about how
people view uh the aiming and I think
they need to we've been working with and
to try and do this I think it's Chris
will know us we want to push it out more
so people can actually see isn't just
about that it's about the good things
they do as well and people might then
sort of have a better understanding that
no it's more than just about uh them
catching the bins and sort of what Nick
actually providers in case a bit of a
community service thank you
okay
um I don't think there's any other
questions
um
just to say
for my part anyway that I'm pleased to
actually see this I think
um councilor when Stanley sort of summed
summed up a lot of what I wanted to say
because
words are you know brilliant but you've
got to deliver on those words and the
only way that you can
um monitor that is through the kpis and
uh you know there is a kind of
commitment
um around all the you know the topics
that you've spoken about and that that
wants to improve the custody customer
offer
um and and the council benefits and you
know the you you've you've put a lot of
bullet points
in in those whether it's a waste or the
governance
um or or whether whether it's three
carbonate carbonization
um you know
the the monitoring of that is going to
be crucial
quite frankly and that's the only way
that we we will made the improvements to
make sure that these are delivered on I
take your point about that you know
we've got to uh
better place but it was really bad place
and so so you know at this moment in
time it's you know average really and
and we want to be I mean you know we're
we're
inspired to to be
really good and then you know that's
what we want to achieve so I I think
scrutiny can play a role in in terms of
um you know that monitoring of kpis and
and stuff like once you've got you know
all that sorted out
um but but I I do thank you for for your
presentations and uh and the work that
has has been done it sounds like it's
it's been a bit of a tough
um and quite a long period of time that
you've negotiated and you know tried to
come together
um with you know what you what you've
presented to us tonight so I thank you
for that
um okay
so thanks very much for coming tonight
thank you much appreciated
I could stay if you want
cheers have a good evening
[Music]
right
um
item eight
um leader of the council's priorities
for 23 24 and Tom has arrived halfway
through the presentations so so thanks
very much for coming Tom and
um you know just just present what
you've got thank you very much chair
thank you and good evening everyone
um what I intend to do is just talk
through a few of the Strategic aims for
the year ahead with a little bit of
information under each one then happy to
take questions so um first things first
um we had our relaunch event of our
strategic partnership yesterday and I
think it's plain to say that we can't do
much without our partners whether you're
talking about Amy as you have just
talked about or whether you're talking
about our housing providers our local
businesses places like Manchester United
UA 92 whether it be public sector
private sector partnership work is key
and that underpins a lot of what we wish
to do as a council it was really good
yesterday that we did see so many people
from the plus across the public and
private sector in the room um it was
oversubscribed which was very
encouraging and one of the early things
that we were looking at is scoping out
what the partnership looks like now post
pandemic and early priorities one of
which and one of the key themes that
came across in that meeting yesterday
was the cost of living price crisis and
addressing the causes of poverty so
there's going to be some work around the
Strategic partnership around that and
clearly that is a very pressing matter
as people look at the interest rate
situation the inflation situation
um we need to look at what we can do
together to try and address some of the
immediate issues that uh that people are
facing in the borough
another priority of mine is something
that you have just spoken at Great
length about which is the Amy seven year
review I'm not intended to say much more
because I have heard a lot from the
conversations and have also seen the the
presentation that you were taken through
by um by by Chris and Helen as well but
clearly that is an incredibly important
part of what we do as a council for our
residents and we need to use this review
as an opportunity to reset as I've heard
people say look at how we make things
more transparent look at how we deliver
better customer focus and service and
that is something I am hoping with the
help of scrutiny we get to fire once the
uh once the review is complete and we
get to Executive with that later on this
year
um clearly a part of the um a part of
the review as you will have seen through
the presentation was looking at Carbon
emissions and how we reduce them and
increase sustainability which leads me
on to my third priority for the year was
he's looking at the climate crisis the
climate emergency
looking at the how we meet our targets
around that as as they're in our carbon
neutral action plan
um I'm pleased to confirm that we have
just recruited ahead of the climate
change
um and also a supporting officer role in
that area we find that when we're able
to find the resource to put into places
it does make a huge impact on what we're
able to do as a Borough so I'm very very
delighted that we were able to make that
appointment uh in the last week
um there's a lot to go on there I was
also equally delighted with my new
position as the Green City region lead
in Greater Manchester I am going to be
using that position a to learn about
good practice that may be happening
across other parts of Greater Manchester
but also further afield and B to look at
emerging ideas so that we can try and
adopt them here and just to really learn
more about the the crisis that we're
facing clearly I know stuff from a
Trafford level but there's a lot of
useful stuff that's happening both on a
region Regional and a national level
that I can now draw on in that role as
Green City region lead
um we're working with Partners to
explore the potential for a district
heat Network you will have seen from the
last executive that we're expanding our
EV charging points and looking at how we
um how we put points into different uh
different areas of the borough
um we are going to be continuing our
investment into active travel exploring
more school streets exploring exploring
more safer places for both cyclists and
pedestrians
um I'm delighted that we were awarded
some money at a May um combined
authority to look at work up up the
Talbot Road Junctions we're looking to
we're looking to progress that along the
a56 as well we're also working to with
our other organizations to support the
installation of solar panels on schools
and other public buildings
um so there's some of the areas around
that very important agenda another
important agenda for Trafford is the
cultural strategy again this will be
coming to Executive hopefully at the end
of this month a lot of work has gone
into together our cultural strategy
again the key is Partners organizations
across Trafford in the arts and culture
sectors of which there are a lot of them
we have all come together and I think
we're going to be producing what is a
very exciting Borough a very exciting
vision for the for the very exciting
strategy very exciting vision for the
for the borough
um there is a lot that we can do with
culture and arts it's incredibly
important part of people's lives and I
do believe that we have been in a way
punching below our weight in Trafford
for many years now and we can harness
the skills the knowledge the creative
Industries we have out there in the
borough and make things better for all
of us and it's not about the council
telling people what to do it's about the
council recognizing how to how to bring
people together and people working with
each other as well so cultural strategy
is very important key regeneration
projects so
um we had a recent planning application
over on the the lamina site the um the
the Civic quarter action plan we've got
the key housing projects so so such as
what is happening in Stratford alongside
the New Town Center master plan we have
the sale magistrates Court development
on on its way as well in Altrincham
we're ongoing works with the Stanford
quarter and the Grafton Center we're
looking at starting work on an urmston
Town Center strategy near the Trafford
Center we know that fur may have put in
another planning application which
they're seeking consideration on which
will produce provide huge regeneration
and job of potential if that gets
through the planning process okay and
we're also looking at a vision for
Waterside as well so that stretch of
land from Pomona across to and including
Media city there's a lot of potential
there and there's work we want to do
around there to to Really maximize the
benefits for Trafford and and get the
most out of that landlab there
the final thing I want to touch on
really is
it does involve a lot of partnership
work and that is to improve health
outcomes for all our children and young
people
clearly that will involve our partners
in the local NHS and all those that sit
around the locality board table and for
those of you that don't know the
locality board is one of the new
governance roles that we have in within
Trafford where we meet on a monthly
basis we are co-chair so I chair
alongside one of our GPS and we take an
alternate turns to uh to chair that
meeting we have representatives from
Health watch the local Health Service
children's Adult Services
um we all come together and obviously
look at the health needs and challenges
that we've got one of the things that I
do wish to focus in on and when it is
also referenced in the greater
Manchester integrated care
plan for
2023-2028 is going back to some of my
initial words on becoming leader giving
children and young people the best
possible start in life so I want to
explore through partnership work how we
improve the health outcomes for all our
children and young people and I
specifically want to do that because I
am conscious that children and young
people have been through a lot in recent
years and that the um the pandemic and
keeping people safe will have had a
disproportionately bigger impact on
children and young people mainly because
of their age you know if if if you're 12
the three years of of of of lockdown and
disruption that's a significant part of
your life so that's something that I'm
very very keen to explore as well as as
a priority going forward there are a lot
of other things I could have added in it
there's a lot going on in Trafford
um but those are the ones that I wanted
to pick out for the purposes of today
and I'm happy to take any questions or
comments
okay thanks very much for that Tom that
very useful to have your take on you
know how we actually move forward as a
as a for a an eight questions
yeah
councilor Jones
yeah thanks Jay and thanks Tom for that
that's really encouraging and we're
looking forward to these things coming
to fruition a couple things of pointers
out or picked out of that law I've got
four things here the first School Street
which is something I really love uh I've
been really
um impressed with what we've been doing
with that I'd just like to know how
we're going to expand that from the
kinds of pilot that we're doing at the
moment and be good to see it happen and
then schools where I'm a governor and
sell and other schools too
and the cultural strategy I know it's
close to your heart does that include
Sports culture too
[Music]
um
a number on the improving Health outcome
for young people you've said the
pandemics impact them greatly mostly
around mental health I'm looking forward
to knowing how we're going to um deal
with that because I think that's a major
thing and just carpent back to what
we've been talking about a lot tonight
the Amy seven year review
are you confident this is going to allow
us to get the basics right for things
that matter to our residents
thank you that's a that's a very good
set of questions and comments there if
you go back to the school streets yes we
are Keen to explore how we expand we've
had as you'll have seen a series of
Trials happening across the borough
there's lessons that we need to learn
from those trials which we will do
there's a question of resource and we
think there is a way of getting a
resource in there in the longer term to
make sure we fund more active travel and
school streets so that is definitely
something on the agenda it's really
important that we take down the barriers
that stop people from walking or cycling
safely to and from schools I know that I
think when we were all well maybe not
everyone but a few of us that are
slightly older above 40. remember when
um when we were
when we could walk or you know cycle to
school and you don't have the you didn't
have the volume of cars that we we do
face now we need to unpick that and we
need to look at safer routes and school
streets is part of that so we're looking
at Lessons Learned From the trials but
we're also identifying ways of funding
School streets in the future we think
we've got that means of doing that and
that will happen in in the longer term
cultural strategy you're absolutely
right yes Sport and Leisure form is a
very important part of our cultural
heritage and sporting Heritage in this
Borough and there is a significant
amount of overlap between the two
um we're very very lucky in Trafford
again to have such key sporting assets
in the borough we're sat in between two
of the international ones but it would
be a remiss not to acknowledge ultragon
football club down the road clearly sail
shocks are beyond our boundaries at the
moment but uh you know they they do I
think they're just still think they
train here if I remember correctly
um you've also got the commute lots and
lots of Beauty groups that happen on a
weekly on a regular basis whether that
be football teams whether that be rugby
whether it be
um handball as well which has got quite
a following in Trafford so yeah
the the sporting and Leisure element of
that is incredibly important which is
one of the reasons why going back to
when I formed the new executive at the
start of the year I very specifically
wanted to have a executive member that
covered leisure arts culture and
Heritage because I feel that their areas
in Trafford that we've got a lot of good
stuff that is how do we harness it how
do we celebrate it how do we promote it
to the world because frankly we're doing
some of it at the moment but there's a
lot more we could do with that in terms
of children's mental health that is one
of the things that when I've been
meeting young people since well before
coming leader but particularly since
becoming leader and looking at what
their priorities are mental health and
access to support is huge that is one of
the biggest things that they tell me
about and some of that will be related
to their experience over the pandemic
other parts will be completely separate
to that again if you think about when we
were all younger we didn't have social
media and that kind of
um cyber bullying anything like that
that could have a real tangible impact
on someone's well-being on top of the
the other things that the young people
can be can be challenged with in in life
as a as they're growing up it is
something we need to work very closely
with
um our partners in in mental health our
contractors there but there's also ways
of looking at what do we do what
measures can we put in
to get in there early to try and to try
and stop things from escalating and when
people are waiting to be seen what
additional support can we think of
around that child around that person
that can help them as they try and seek
support so yeah mental health is quite
right you picked up on that because that
is the big thing that young people have
been saying to me over the past six
months and the final thing about Amy I'm
I'm
optimistic I'm more optimistic than the
than Chris seemed to be then I I do
think a lot of work has gone into the
seven year review and members that have
been around this table for a few years
will acknowledge that it's been longer
than we probably anticipated because it
is such a complex piece of work that
we've had to do around that I think what
is looking to come to Executive once
negotiations are over is infinitely
better than what was started at the one
Trafford partnership a few years ago so
I am optimistic that we will get it
right but it's going to be incredibly
important for the members of the public
for the local residents to get to see
the transparency get to see when
services are working well uh get to know
when Services aren't working so well so
some of the things that I've discussed
is like having a public-facing dashboard
so people can see that it's it's
important that members get kept in the
loop and I feel encouraged that we will
be and I would encourage anyone who's
not been to it to go down to the Depot I
spent a morning there a few months ago
now and it brought to life all the I.T
measures that they talked about and the
way they identify where bin wagons are
going hit it is such a valuable use of
time so if you get a chance and I know
that they're very open to visitors go
down to the depot it is well worth a
couple of hours of your time and it does
help when responding to your local
residents
any other questions
yeah counselor Walsh if it's possible uh
Tom could this strategic partnership was
relaunched Jesse so how would that work
in practice so going forward for the
next 12 months
okay what will be happening now is
there's going to be a kind of scoping a
little bit more work about what the
Strategic partnership would look like
what is its most effective way of
running clearly the last time we had an
in-person strategic partnership it was
pre-pandemic
um we've used this opportunity to look
at what works for people we fought a a
blended approach what we want to see is
not the council leading it the council
has a very important Civic role within
it but we want to make sure there is a
role and Leadership roles for business
and other partners around the world
around the room so we all have a stake
in the in the partnership going forward
and there will be more information as we
firm up the the details around how the
partnership will work and I'm I'd be
very happy
um to come back and give a a full
briefing on on the partnership what we
are agreeing to look at in the short
term and what the longer term aims of
the partnership will be um but I have to
say yesterday it again with with
optimistic optimism I was incredibly
impressed by the number of people that
took two hours out of their day to come
to us in sale and sit around the table
and look at what we do better between us
all for the residents of the borough
foreign
[Music]
young people
um and and you know the outcomes uh for
for those children
um
I think we we do have a great asset in
gorse hill with the ghost Hill Studios
as as you you you absolutely know
um and it's how we actually develop
places like that
um around the borough really because I
think it's really necessary for that to
to to happen because the work that they
do for young people
um and children in in care and you know
uh a lot of special needs young people
as well and it's incredible what they
what they do and I think we need
you know those kind of spaces uh right
around the borough because obviously
we've had a decline in youth centers and
and all of that over the last 12 years
or so and you know I think I think we we
should we should be trying to at least
you know develop those places for for
young people
thank you on ghost Hill Studios I mean
they do do a fantastic job and indeed
Debbie from Ghost Hill Studios was at
the partnership event yesterday one of
the things that we discussed was a sense
of place where the community to come to
as a kind of front door for support and
access as a way of
hopefully stopping things from
escalating so that was one of the things
also an observation about a ghost here
because clearly we were both went to a
performance uh last week and I just
thought that Titan
several things altogether engaged young
people it was a fantastic act at play
that was put on that was very much
informed by experiences young people
have had whether it be well there's
there's a series of very quite heavy
issues that they that they focus on as
part of that play but it was also a way
of using culture to bring the best out
of young people and that's why culture
is incredibly important it's a way of
supporting helping getting the best out
of people so ghost Hill they don't just
they just do that they do a lot of stuff
and like the same our talk Shop in sale
the amount of reach and interaction that
they have with younger people is is
fantastic again if you ever get a chance
to visit either ghost Hill Studios or
talk shop please do because they are
doing some our offices the people who do
the stuff of course who are doing some
amazing stuff with young people we also
have to ask younger people what they'd
like to see so that is something that we
need to engage with but to say the the
key message I've had back clearly Health
outcomes for everyone's important Health
outcomes for younger people is one of
the things that I'm particularly
interested in but one of the things
going back to uh Will's question was um
you know mental health that is the big
thing that they're saying is is a
concern for them so any way that we can
find by working together to make things
better for younger people we're very
much open for that
thank you if there's no other questions
uh can I thank you very much for coming
along uh tonight I know that we and
you're that advocate of scrutiny and uh
I know that within the review
um it was
um stated that we'd want the leader to
come to our first meeting which you have
done now and I know that you'll uh be
present at a few more of them so thank
you for your support thank you very much
I'll try not to beat my record of last
year when I think I was all but one
scrutiny meeting but uh yeah I look
forward to seeing you very very soon and
thank you and keep up the good work what
you're all doing in scrutiny because
it's incredibly important to us from a
governance perspective as well so thank
you
right
um the next item is item nine uh the
committee work program
we did have an informal meeting
um thinking I can't remember when it was
it was about two weeks ago I think
um and and we did draw up a draft
of
um
items that we'd want to look at
throughout the year we already have a
number of items on on the go and two
task and finish groups uh one is the
um the the the issues around Manchester
United football ground
um and the reduction of car dependency
um so they they will be an ongoing
um piece of work that we we will be
doing I think the other items
that I think has been listed
um with which you will
be able to see for yourself
um uh the
one of them is the access accessibility
of council Services
um and and we thought that was quite an
important issue and to look at at how
easily Trafford residents are able to
contact the council online through email
or phone and to to the access uh cert to
access Services
um
and
yeah I think I think that was
scored on importance
for
and the impact for
um dampen mold with rented accommodation
was another
and that was to really look at uh the
performance of housing associations in
tackling damp and mold within the
properties uh it is something obviously
um that has been a cause of concern for
residents
and nothing you know mid councilor fuss
were promoting
that as an issue
um and that scored uh important for
and the impact for
um there was
retrofitting of a accommodation in
Trafford which Jill suggested and that
would look at the work housing providers
are doing to retrofit properties and
whether it meets a progress expected
with the council's carbon neutral
action plan and I think again they
scored for
um
Carrington relief Road and and
this is something that either Carry On
from last
um Municipal year and
um to to have reports come to this
committee
periodically throughout the year
so
um that is one that you know I think we
we supported when we met
um
now
what we have to take on board is the
the
capacity that we have in terms of
Officer support and so on
um and it's
you know it's it's going to be difficult
to
um
to do others and there are a few others
that have been
spoken about tonight and
uh and with it with with the leader
um and I think the Amy review
I think it would be worth having
um you know periodic
uh
notification of what they're actually
doing in terms of delivering on
on the
um that that review and all the
proposals that they've got and looking
at the kpis and so on
um
um so it's open to you really
um you know you want to uh look at
anything else
um we'll have we'll we'll have to look
at it
in a way that
um you know doesn't create huge amounts
of work
councilor Coggins
[Music]
um thanks yeah as you know I was away
for that meeting I did feed some
suggestions in through Alex which she
assured me were
um
uh still in time to be considered and
they were
um
uh the tht to lnq Handover how's it
going what impact has been for residents
and so on it obviously could overlap to
some extent with the damp and other
issues or it may or may not
um
The Wildflower planting and better
mowing practices we've I know we've been
dabbling in lately it seems like this
huge potential to expand that so to know
how it's going where what's working
what's not working it needs Improvement
in related to that Community allotments
Food growing so we've got a lot of
unused land basically
that's that's lawn at the moment can we
can we make more of it Wildflower
Meadows can we use some of the food
growing community allotments and so on
and the third was about public toilet
access which I think cancer Jerome has a
detail on
Financial brought to my attention by a
number of community groups that has
spoken about it and individual residence
just about the the lack of access to
free public toilets for instance if you
look at altering an interchange and that
has the only real public toilet that's
open seven days a week but yet it's
behind blocked barred Gates where you
need to pay 20p to get in so it excludes
many people on accessibility grounds
um and there does seem to be a paucity
of kind of free toilets where anybody
could just walk in and use them on a
regular basis and I'm just wondering
whether this scrutiny committee could
could look at it do an audit of the
public toilets across the borough
um probably look at the accessibility
issue around those toilets but also
maybe look at Solutions and how we could
address maybe a shortfall in provision
such as looking at Partnerships with
businesses organizations and
um I did when I my idea in I did speak
to counselor Harding who had done some
work on this around the
um age well board and passed on some of
the detail around that which I submitted
to Alex which maybe could be shared but
uh but I wanted to know what the
committee thought of that idea and
whether it was something that could be
feasibly taken on
can I just suggest that maybe that could
be looked out within some kind of active
travel concept because active travel
kind of does mean that there should be
more public toilets so that people can
walk more and also things like having
you know like lots of seats and benches
on the Pavements and that kind of thing
so that was just a thought but I wasn't
going to ask I was really asking about
the the suggestions by the executive
members and how they fitted into what we
were doing picture on the bottom of the
list yeah
hey it's indeed um
I'm just whilst you're speaking about um
because of this issue that you've raised
I mean it could come to this committee
but I think
um it probably lies more in the health
kind of Realm because uh access to
toilets leads to uh and lack of it Lisa
social isolation and the problems of
loneliness and
um especially in the age community and
like all the problems that causes
um around social care and like the loss
of mobility and all these things that
kind of stem from that so I think it
probably Falls more under the health
screening committees remitted than this
one but we can uh I mean the community
thinks that it's a problem that of scale
that should be
um looked at then you can obviously
recommend it to the health recruiting
committee and put a bit more weight
behind that they should accept it
but also given the scale of the problem
it'll probably be a task and finish
group rather than just a short piece of
work yeah I mean I think I think that's
um quite a good idea really
um because it does
no touch on their remit really in the
health scrutiny
um
I think
I think I think if if
um I don't know whether you've got a
representation on on the health
committee if you have then I think you
know raise it there
um and I think at least that could
happen is to get the audit
sorted and then that that actually will
spin on to other other issues so I mean
I thought I think what's been suggested
by Alex is probably the right way to go
on that
um yeah
okay Jill you said about the other
the list on the bottom of the list
there's some yeah executive member
suggestions as well
which haven't been no they they haven't
and they haven't been given any scores
no no they haven't so so
there are a number of issues that
um
that have been
sent centered by the
um the executive members
um
ICT
security to look at the current position
of the council's digital
security risk to council systems and
possible action to mitigate those risks
um
I think that was suggested by
the leader
um
but then went on to say
but will consult with Paul James about
providing further details the committee
are waiting further information from the
leader before
providing this item as a score so you
know that that's a possibility later in
the year I would have thought
um
Devolution Trailblazer
this is an area that the committee feel
could be of significant importance and
impact put our awaiting further
information
before providing a score
so have we got any other information
around those two I believe it was
Council Oxford who thought that who
would get more
um information on our GM level around
the Trailblazer and yeah I suggest the
Devolution Trailblazer but what I'm
thinking is that we've got so many
things haven't we I don't know how we
how we prioritize them really and
I think how yeah how we work with gmca I
think is really important but then so a
lot of other things yeah
okay
um
Financial
sustainability affordable of Key
Programs and the finance and change
program this was suggested by the
executive member for finance
change and governance
Director of Finance and systems
so I mean I think we do get
reports don't we quarterly reports
around the budget and maybe we could fit
it into something
around that
and again the
um the next one was understanding why
Council fail and issue
section 114 notices including the
importance of the Prudential framework
I don't know much about that
suggestion by the executive member for
finance
and the Director of Finance
yeah those three items at the bottom
they've all come from the same Source
yeah um and they've recognized that they
are very technical areas but they've
offered uh briefing sessions to the
committee if they wanted to be informed
about them and then go from there to see
if you would like to scrutinize them in
detail yeah
um could we kind of get them to come to
one of our meetings and explain a little
bit more about them before we kind of
delve into them and start doing a bit of
training because I know I need some
training on them
probably do um I'm just concerned about
taking up the limited amount of time
yeah
teams mean yeah that's it um I'll uh
email everyone if the committee agrees
with that then I can email and we can
get some dates set out
you would need to know what what you're
talking about wouldn't you really so I
mean if for me it strikes me that those
last four perhaps are more appropriate
for the accounts and Order committee
than for this commission yeah
um and I think having been on that
committee there are all things live in
Canada and there's quite a lot of
training out there
um I just wonder if we need to go down
that road given that we have quite a lot
of other stuff that other committees
can't do yeah no I I I think that's
correct
um but obviously you know we we did
ask for executive members to
put forward some suggestions it doesn't
mean to say that we have to accept them
and I think the points have been made
are are good points and uh
so
I don't think we've got the time to be
able to do that
so has anybody else got any other issues
yeah just thinking about about the Amy
contracts and uh
you know it was strategic that report we
got that I think if we were going to
look at something that we think will
have will have improved and I'm
optimistic as the leader said could we
look at a service in depth when I say in
depth
of a specific service rather than
looking at the whole thing again so you
know whatever it was a particular
element of the Amy contract and just
just checking that out for a scrutiny
yeah I mean the
the the the the waste and the
um the the green
issues you know the carbon reduction
would be good ones to to to look at in
in more depth
um I mean the waste one seems to be
the ones where
most counselors kept problems and so so
it'd be worth
and trying to
you know say sick in six months time or
something like that that we could have a
another report on those specific things
within the Strategic plans that they've
got
um that's a if that's acceptable
yeah
okay
yeah I mean it strikes me looking
through these there are some recurring
themes so there's the dampened mold and
rented accommodation there's the
retrofitting which is obviously closely
related to damp and mold Housing
Development and the one I suggested
about THC becoming lnq it strikes me
that between all those is obviously
quite a desire to talk about
housing and how it's been affecting
People's Health and climate
um I just wonder if we can conflate some
of these and then there's also
um obviously the weeds and the green
spaces are related and then there's the
high amp and character relief Road are
probably less related but
um it just seems like maybe we could
conflate rather than sort of Crossing
out some of them is actually quite a lot
of overlap and does that make sense
could we conflate a few of these
suggestions into
one issue say like I think the Retro
fitting accommodation could could
actually fit in with the dam because
um you know we will be asking the
housing associations to come along and
they could talk about both issues really
and potentially also about the change
from tht telling Q at this time yeah and
and that yeah sorry yeah
so the three issues that we would we
could just put you know ask them to come
along uh with answers on the three
questions we we can put those questions
to them
prior to the coming
yeah I think that makes sense
the weeds and the green spaces would
then have a overlap as well
yeah I'd say that those are more like
kind of themes that you'd have for
meetings rather than like um the
overlapping of the
particular issues because I mean uh how
much detail you're wanting on each issue
like and how much
um
like if you go into the dump then the
retrofitting would and you had them
covered together the Retro 13 would be
like a make up a very small part of that
I think the damp would definitely
be the main issue that you can cover in
whereas if you're asking for separate
reports on those items you'll probably
get more in terms of the Retro thing as
well so I think in terms of scheduling
that definitely works better like so get
all the people who are related to the
things in the same room and so when
we're looking at which
because we've just agreed that there are
certain ones that you're definitely
going to schedule but I haven't put any
on the work program yet because I didn't
know how you wanted to do it this year
so are you wanting to look towards that
kind of like a thematic scheduling over
the course of the year
yeah I think I think we will need to do
that
um
but I think I think
what what would happen if we did put
those three issues that we we've just
talked about
into one sort of letter sent to
um the the housing associations
asking them to come along to you know
give us an overview of what they are
doing in those three areas and then we
can decide what we want to do following
that meeting really
um whether we want to split it up or
whatever really
because I think they are all important
issues so it's three
um and just bring in you know
um bringing them in separately would
yeah it does sound a bit you know
cumbersome really
yeah just thinking about the weeds and
I'm not quite in the weeds and The
Wildflower and rewarding and that kind
of issue we could look at that under the
Amy thing and we could ask Amy to we
could look at two maybe two areas in one
meeting
um whatever we thought was most
important I'd certainly be interested in
looking at
yeah um the wildflowers and stuff yeah
thanks I'm just I'm just conscious of
Alex if if we're adding things in there
you can you can manage all that you know
you want a good Village topic justice
but if
if he thinks that's that's manageable
then then that's fine
yeah as long as you keep two around
um maximum of three big item ticket
items per agenda I think you can manage
them uh with some things as well like
when you're saying about the Amy seven
year review it might be an idea to
um at some point have a conversation
around their kpis and how they could
provide like a regular report to this
committee kind of like similar to what
was done previously around homelessness
where like it's an area that you're
interested in and you can get a regular
data report like a scorecard that you
can keep an eye on and then you can
bring things in when you identify any
issues that you want to address directly
um but so you kept well informed but you
don't have to keep on covering it at
each meeting if you want to know as well
I still think do the Deep dive but I
think you'd probably want to keep a an
eye on the whole breadth of the contract
if you know what I mean
I think we're delegating you to to get
this down on
the page really with Alex chair
and then see if we're all happy about it
after that show you circulating